I don't even you know you're the one
guess I don't have to ask if you're in a
splint I don't even know yeah it's just
called not going to college
[Laughter]
decision-making no no it's it's working
well for you do not change now you know
I got to meet your co-star nine-year-old
Jackson Nicoll he was on the show the
other day and he did you know he was a
kindred spirit when you met him cuz he's
a he's an interesting kid little angel
right I went in this true story I went
in backstage to say hi to him and he was
playing cards with his manager Mike hi
and he's like it's crazy I met him when
he was 7 I met him on a movie and he
comes up to me cuz I've seen your movies
and I said yeah they're pretty silly
right he goes by silly you mean stupid
and then he comes over to me and hits me
right square in the zipper he has a
fascination with doing that he's good at
it he's very good at he's really good at
it it doesn't take a lot of skills he's
Craig goes my career so he punched you
in the zipper and he thought this is the
kid for me ok I can use him
I honestly that's exactly what I thought
I he's just fearless and he was on
attack mode the whole time and I thought
he's perfect for jackass and then I'm
like oh well we're developing this other
film and so we got him in for this okay
the you you taught him something called
the double high-five well double
high-five you me show you no no I want
you to tell me about it
I've known you too long I don't want you
to show me I wouldn't do that to you
uh well I said Jackson you know it's
good to ask someone for a double
high-five you go up and put your hands
up for double high-five and soon as they
raise their hands with their hands up
you lay him right out in the zipper
that's a terrible thing to teach it
chuckle no he's great at it and
and we executed that we were doing a
movie with victoria justice sweetheart
and her boyfriend also very sweet but he
was standing next to us I'm like give
him the double high-five
and it worked magically we got Victoria
justices got a boyfriend to put his
hands up and I think we have a after
shot of him and there's a shot of you
guys I think yeah happy everything like
we really accomplished something we are
so happy the rest of the night now is
this true that you you trait you you
shot a scene and I saw the scene that
you shot in a male strip club but I
didn't know if this is a place that you
had been before you've been to a male
strip club before and no was it was
offers no I've been to him before I you
know female strip clubs are weird
because you don't know where to look
exactly but I went to a male strip club
with John Waters when we were promoting
The Dirty Shame and it was amazing it's
just all the guys were wearing sailors
hats and smiles and that's it and yeah I
had a pocketful of ones Conan now this
true also you you you recently traced
your family's genealogy
unfortunately yes I heard a lot of
people do that and it's a it's a it's a
fascinating thing to find out where you
come from well that was my thought going
in and then I heard a really good
genealogist and you know he's very
straight-laced and buttoned up and one
day he calls me and I'm like what would
we learn now and he goes uh sit down and
he said you know in these rural mountain
regions you come from no one ever goes
into the community and no one ever
leaves the community and at that point I
started laughing and he said so it's not
uncommon that there's inbreeding in
those communities and I said is there in
breeding in my family he said I
shouldn't a significant amount happy
yeah he thought I used given me a really
horrible thing and I was I had tears
rolling down my face I'm just very happy
I can't wait to tell this on Cole
[Laughter]